well several obnoxious left-wing
activists tailed senator kirsten cinema
from a classroom at arizona state to the
restroom and harassed her outside a
stall
now i'll admit i've done this myself
while drunk but it had nothing to do
with politics
and everything to do with the missing
bag of weed that julie bandera still
owes me
but instead of giving the senator some
privacy they just continued their
business while she did hers
that our people need in order for us to
be able to talk about what's really
happening we need a buildback better
plan right now
[Music]
we knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us oh
yeah that'll win converts to your side
asu's always been a party school but now
it's a potty school
but i'm impressed by the senator if
someone ever recorded me in the bathroom
stall the audio would sound like a miles
davis solo
so
why were these activists so outraged
well they claim it's because she wasn't
supporting joe's build back better
agenda but we know that's bs they don't
even read it they don't care but they
chased her into the stall
assuming that she's a girl and won't
fight back
but kirsten if you're listening we'll
take you over mitt romney any day
you know how to make the tough choices
and you look better in thigh high boots
here's what the president had to say
mr president
mr president uh you're talking about how
you have
48 democratic votes right now the other
two
have been pressured over the weekend by
activists joe manchin had people on
kayaks show up to his boat tl adam
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service standing
around them
um so it's it's part of the process yes
what did he just say
sometimes i think he's just playing
scrabble with us in his head
but this kind of invasive harassment is
the type of discourse the left champions
from harassing diners to looting
businesses it's all part of the same
strategy and it's no coincidence they do
some of their best work in the toilet
they don't give a crap even if you're
giving a crap
even worse they refuse to spare a square
i don't know if someone followed me into
the bathroom holding a camera phone i
think it wouldn't end well
[Music]
compliment to the hood 24 hours a day
all my life
yes
first of all who follows you into a
bathroom filming you why can't they do
it the right way and hide the camera
it's completely inappropriate and why i
always bring my sketching pad
but most people would clobber that creep
especially if you were with a kid at the
time now i assume the media would care
about this invasion of privacy except
they always side with the protesters
that's why their ratings are heading
into the toilet as well i wonder where
this could lead
david rooks for the chess news network
sir we're covering the kirsten cinema
story here at arizona state university
uh are you kirsten cinema
no i'm not this is a bathroom can i get
some privacy no there's no privacy here
at arizona state university
you're at the university of arizona
arizona state university now identifying
as the university of arizona you heard
it here first back to you barn
we saw this coming remember everyone is
politically deputized by the democrats
now to get into your face science
doesn't even matter or in this case
biology last week we told you how the
cdc has gotten rid of the term a woman
when discussing pregnancy that's both
sexist and misogynist and boy have the
broads been complaining
[Laughter]
the washington post joined in
saying that reporters will now be
expected to write pregnant individuals
because not all pregnant people are
women the complete phrase pregnant women
and other pregnant individuals
meaning i suppose men
but once again a reminder to all you
narrow-minded types yes men can get
pregnant i refer to the men who have
ovaries and wombs and can fertilize an
egg and bring a baby to term
oh wait men don't have that stuff
and good luck trying if you put a
mercedes engine in a toyota it's still a
toyota
but mention the science you risk
marginalizing someone who would that be
good question i hate to tell you but
who's getting marginalized here is women
men now appear on playboy it's happened
before but this is different yeah check
this out a half naked dude on the cover
hugh hefner and three dead chicks must
be turning in his grave
the only way you get a joke out of three
dead chicks is that joke of hugh hefner
yes i hope he gets a lot of exposure
over this but be careful young man you
don't want to get pregnant
he's a social media influencer
apparently yeah he's influenced me to
order my own pair of those platform
shoes
so tired of borrowing dana's
but i get it playboy is a dead brand and
the only way to breathe it back to life
is going woke hoping you get attention
from the twitter mobs and because it's a
slow news day we ate it right up it was
between that and a story
about biden putting his shoes in the
microwave by accident
or was it by accident we don't know
the fact is all of these things have one
thing in common vapid stupidity the
activists who chase people into
bathrooms are stupid and vapid the
people who demand you say pregnant
individuals are stupid and vapid and
anyone who took over playboy magazine
stupid stupid stupid and vapid
they've decided to live in a nonsense
world and drag the rest of us into it
all the stupidity makes me miss
nashville for it has a dome of
impenetrable common sense that protects
it from such idiocy and we need to
expand that dome or at least move under
it drew i have grits in my pants and
gravy and my navel but it was worth it
now i'm back and it's good to see
nothing's changed and as a man who needs
to use the bathroom i couldn't be
happier i feel my water breaking or
maybe i just need to pee
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's a new york republican
meaning he's the only new york
republican congressman gubernatorial
candidate lee zeldin
there you go
she's so southern she moon she uses
moonshine as mouthwash
boss business anchor david mcdowell
she's such a diva she'll get the person
who wrote this fired fox news
contributor cat tim
he's so strong even monday won't mess
with him my massive sidekick in the
nwa's world television
all right dagon i am a little bit
reluctant to ask you what you would do
but i assumed what yeah i already know
what you would do but let's say somebody
followed you in the bathroom with a
camera phone
it's not would they be killed it's how
quickly would they be
i'm a lesson teacher i like people who
come for me i like to teach them lessons
i also have the ability to make
even like andy cuomo uncomfortable or
harvey weinstein somebody like that so
if you follow me in the bathroom we're
gonna have a little chitchat while i cop
a squat
and i'm leaving the stall door wide
open
and i'm going to film it and i'm going
to sit there and go
can you go get me some teepee i ran out
do you um have any tic tacs because my
breath isn't very fresh i'm gonna ensure
that nobody ever follows anybody into a
bathroom again
all right tyrus i have i was gonna say
she was gonna bless their heart but
that's that's pretty much the same thing
i i don't know why we're calling these
people activists we need to stop giving
these titles to these morons they
followed a woman into the bathroom
that's harassment they're harassers
there's nothing political there they
didn't they're not doing any favors
there was nothing that they asked her
that couldn't wait for her to come out
of the bathroom except they tried to
intimidate a woman in the bathroom the
last time i checked that is a big crime
to follow someone into the bathroom
recording them without permission and
basically threatening their job
and the most ignorant and the most well
he stopped because he sent the hitman in
but the
the one who gets genius of the day was
one that took literally 12 sentences to
say we we we knocked on doors we got to
do elections
i have never seen a political debate
going
we have 1.5 knocks on doors
opposed to the other team's votes so
we're in they're idiots they but they
believe they're so powerful because they
were going to tweet this out they think
they're heroes because we call them
things like influencers activists
this has never been a safer time in this
country to be an activist because why
there's no opposition
so yeah they're real brave attacking
those and they're being put up as like
they were doing something special
they're not they're harassers and we
need to start calling them that yeah
does this happen to you i mean the weird
thing about this congressman is that uh
we have obnoxious people on the right
but we don't do this stuff like it's so
it's only directed because they believe
that their heart and morality is in the
right place if you were a non-liberal
then you are somehow evil and that
excuses any behavior although i don't
think they've thought that far in vets i
do think these are morons
um what are your thoughts on this i mean
this happened to me earlier today not
following me into a restroom i'm just
trying to go to my office and they're
all waiting outside trying to create a
moment to go viral they were waiting
outside of the front door of our
building here inside of the the city uh
the other extreme of this is when
we had colleagues in the house of
representatives a few years ago where
steve scalise almost lost his life i
mean some of these people they follow
uh their leaders they're the maxine
waters who asks for confrontation they
take it to the next level and thank god
for the capitol police uh they saved a
whole bunch of people's lives i i mean
obviously the tactic is wrong
uh if i'm cinema i don't think this
helps convince me to vote for their
several trillion dollar montrosity of a
bill i think this would actually make me
less likely to vote for the bill
but i i mean i would say that you know
as far as cinema goes regardless uh she
did make the best of what was situations
[Laughter]
you got my vote for governor for just
saying
you know cat there is an interesting
thing about how there's an uh a
distorted outsized view of their power
because of their online presence and you
have a guy who uh portrayed himself as a
moderate now just going woke because he
thinks that these people their opinions
matter more and there's no opposition
yeah it was interesting to me that there
was no even hesitation to follow her in
there and it wasn't just her in there
yeah you watch the full like there's
people coming in and out of the other
stalls that's true how are those people
doing yeah that's true and flushing it
over the sound yeah you know
nobody sees that and thinks like oh
that's okay there are people who see
that and say it's okay
because they have the same problem as
those people do they are in their little
bubble and they think that they're doing
the right thing but if you're following
someone into the bathroom
you've always gone too far yes that is
true no matter what bathroom it is it
doesn't even have to be a gender
gendered bathroom can you beat somebody
up in the bathroom yes thank you wait
you can beat somebody up anywhere you
can beat somebody up and you know but i
mean if that it's like if the police
come can that
it is against the law to film somebody
in the bathroom is it against let's say
i find out that that's my wife in there
and it's like there's a guy in there i
can clobber him right there's a lot to
work with too the commodes the porcelain
is very hard oh usually one shot and
then you set them on the toilet and
nobody will bother them oh yes and then
you close the door and then you walk
away and you go let's go snoop
come on i don't think that was fiction
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilny and i'm
ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis